at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
ethnic cleansing the united states
condemns ongoing violence in ethiopia
which has caused 300
000 people to leave their homes new camp
residents
are arriving all the time although i
don't think you can call this a
displacement camp
it's more like a test of human endurance
hopes for the high street the government
promises millions to help devastated
businesses get ready for the end of
lockdown
an emergency break germany on the brink
of tougher coved restrictions
after the country was hit by a further
wave of infections
still barred we report on the crisis in
the pub industry
one year after they were first told to
close their doors
in sport fulham's premier league
survival hopes suffer a blow with defeat
to leeds
will there be some spring sunshine i'll
have the answer for you later in the
programme
and at quarter two we'll take a look at
the newspapers with the editor of the
young people's news site challenges
northern ireland thomas copeland and the
broadcaster and journalist
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the numbers are huge and still growing
more than half a million people are now
in internal exile in ethiopia forced
from their homes by warfare
into camps unable to cope under the
weight of numbers
months of conflict between ethiopia's
national defense force and
fighters from the tigray people's
liberation front have created a
catastrophic human crisis
seen firsthand by a sky news team the
violence in the tigray region began
in november the united nations estimates
more than half a million people have
been displaced
and nearly 60 000 refugees have fled to
neighboring sudan
earlier this week our africa
correspondent and his team were the
first tv journalist to visit the
villages south
of the regional capital mckelly when
locals claim
massacres have occurred they've now
traveled to north cherry
where a catastrophic humanitarian
situation is unfolding
this is john sparks report
[Music]
there is an elementary school in shure
that offers some sort of sanctuary
a place of refuge for people on the run
but they have arrived in a city now
gripped by a humanitarian
emergency and there is little here to
keep them alive
there is no food and there is no shelter
and there is no
the basic needs so if you can
you have to address the world to come
soon
a human tide of 300 000 are now camping
in this beleaguered city after a
hazardous journey from
western tigray and many here
both young and old are struggling how
are you tell me how you're feeling
some have been forced to flee their
homes others have been
banished by militias from the
neighboring region of amhara
the u.s government has called it ethnic
cleansing
and her daughter have just arrived in
shuri
this must be a really difficult time
called humera and she says she's lost
everything
she owns do you know where you are going
to sleep tonight
there's not much space at sahaya
elementary
and conditions at five other camps in
the city are the same
the air filled with smoke and the
continuous sound of people
coughing it's so claustrophobic in here
there's
barely any room to move inside and new
camp residents
are arriving all the time although i
don't think you can call this a
displacement camp
it's more like a test of human endurance
how are you feeling
on earth
no food no services at this elementary
school
twenty-eight-year-old fitzsim
teclahimanot
from a mental illness and his father a
priest
has decided to keep him in chains it's
the only way they can cope
with
until recently and the local hospital
can't meet demand this is the corridor
of the main reception
they are short of beds and routine
medication
like basic pain relief this man was
stitched up without an anesthetic
during our visit they know the thirty
among the fifth sometimes the war in
tigre
has put everyone under terrible pressure
says the director
as the physicians we are we we are doing
our best
but it's really harsh the environment is
harsh the time is harsh
and still our staffs are also still they
have this psychological trauma including
me psychological trauma because one of
our best pharmacy staff was killed with
his family by the birthrangers
gunshot wounds and shrapnel injuries
have become a matter of routine
but some patients can't just be patched
up
eight-year-old al abraham was shot in
the head
by militiamen in western tigray
his mother grandmother and brother were
killed
i don't have an idea because he's too
young he's eight years old
later on him his little brother is five
years old
killed by them even they thought that
this was already dead
but later on as you can see there is two
sides of the injury you can see
one was it's a bullet injury and it was
in and
by that side it was also the police was
get out with us
they've been caught in the middle of a
battle for power
and the war in tigre will never leave
them
john sparks sky news in shuri
after a year in which more than 41 000
retail jobs were lost the government has
pledged extra funding to smarten up town
centres for the end of lockdown
but with non-essential shots still weeks
away from reopening
tourism officials say struggling towns
could need
more money milena vasilinovich reports
from somerset
paul batz's shop has everything you need
for an outdoor adventure
the store has supplied equipment for
trips to mount everest kilimanjaro and
ben nevis
but in a year when most of us have been
staying at home
the business has struggled we've lost
all our
key customers because you know duke of
edinburgh award was cancelled ten tours
was cancelled scouting's been on halt
and a lot of our customers are traveling
the world all the time we're equipping
people for
adventures all over the world normally
and that's just not happening
this is just one of the shops in the
seaside town of western superman
struggling to stay afloat in the
pandemic retail is one of the industry's
worst hit by covid
almost 10 000 chain stores disappeared
in 2020
and over 41 500 people in the sector
lost their jobs but today the government
has announced new funding for high
streets and coastal towns
hoping to give them a boost ahead of
summer we're providing over 55 million
pounds so that councils can give that
money to
high streets to town centres to city
centres the length and breadth of the
country
and that they can use it to tidy up to
plant
to invest in new seating to market and
advertise their high streets
and to lay on some great events this
spring and summer
so that we can all get back out back
those independent retailers
the money is a good start those in the
tourism industry say
but it doesn't go far enough to cover
the huge losses caused by the pandemic
we saw about 70 percent of our turnover
our business
completely wiped out over that period of
time
which is has been an absolute it's just
been devastating for us
um however we're now seeing that pent up
demand
and we're hoping to see a resurgence
coming back through
and for the for this this particular
summer
as shops and pubs prepare to reopen in
april there's optimism that warmer
weather and shrinking virus numbers will
bring customers
but recovery can only start business
owners say
if this lockdown truly is the last one
milena veselinovich sky news
germany appears likely to introduce
tougher lockdown restrictions as it
struggles with a growing number of
coronavirus cases
the chancellor angela merkel has said
the government will have to apply
what she called an emergency break a
three-day pause in the vaccination
program and a slow
take-up rate means just eight percent of
the population have received the
injection
far below rates in britain and the
united states
the department of health has released
the latest coronavirus figures in the uk
there were under 5 000 new covert 19
cases reported
with 101 more deaths across the uk
that takes the total number of people
who've died to 126
026 and 26.26 million first doses of
vaccine
have now been given when our political
correspondent rob powell joins me now
from westminster and rob with this new
wave of uh covered 19 in europe just how
worried are the government here i think
they'll be very alert to what's going on
on the continent jillian because
remember think back to
september last year and the beginning of
the second wave
and a precursor to cases rising in the
uk
was an increase in cases in countries
like france
and germany of course the key difference
this time around
is the vaccine and the high level
relatively anyway of
adults in the uk that have had the
vaccine so far of course we saw the
prime minister getting his first
jab of the astrazeneca vaccine yesterday
almost 50 percent on track to reach 50
percent in the coming days of adults in
the uk will have received
the jab you compare that to the eu where
the number on average
is around 12 so i think even if cases go
up and i think the expectation is
they probably will in the coming weeks
and months here as restrictions
um are eased the vaccine will break that
link between
cases rising and hospitalizations and
deaths rising as well
i think what maybe is a concern when you
look at international travel though
is the risk of variants new variants of
the virus coming into the country
that are potentially more resistant to
the vaccine we heard yesterday from
one member of the government's
scientific advisory panel professor neil
ferguson
who said he was concerned about the
number of straight the number of cases
of the variant first identified in south
africa that were circulating in france
he said that the government should
perhaps think about putting france on
that red list of countries
where there's mandatory quarantine in
hotels when you get back
now no indication from the government as
yet that it is going to put countries
like france
on that list but we have heard in the
past that they will not hesitate to act
quickly if there is a need to tighten
border restrictions
non-essential international travel is
due to start at the earliest from
mid-may
a task force at the moment is looking at
how that can happen
i think if there is a fresh wave of
covert raging on the continent
and a prevalence a high prevalence of
new variants you would imagine some
level of restrictions to stay in place
rob thank you let's go back
now to one of our top stories this
morning and planned by the government to
give around
56 million pounds to help the uk's high
streets
let's speak to adrian waddell chief
executive of any one limited which
supports newcastle's
business district um first of all tell
us about the work that anyone does and
how you support the local economy
good morning we are the city center's
business improvement
district company so we represent around
1400 businesses
in newcastle and have done since 2009.
sorry your sound was uh breaking up a
little bit there
but you were saying that you support
local business how has the the last year
been for you um it's been it's been
pretty desperate
um i mean we are made of resilient stuff
in
newcastle um we've been in and out of
lockdown in many cases longer than
other parts of the uk and of course all
eyes
are on the 12th of april um and really
looking forward to
getting out getting going and welcoming
customers back into town
what exactly have businesses been up
against um
and what sort of changes have they made
how have they had to adapt
to to the situation they find themselves
in i mean i think as we've seen across
the country
there's lots of businesses have had to
close they've had to remodel
their offer and of course in a busy city
centre
a lot of officers have been away and
still are away
hospitality largely has been closed
and the the challenge really and the and
also the great opportunity
for us um we hope after the on the 12th
of april and afterwards
is really is being able to welcome
people back into the city center and
businesses have been incredibly
resilient about how they're going to do
that and there's been a lot of
investment in
internal spaces in planning including
with the city council about how
we can make the most of outdoor spaces
and and get the city really looking its
best and attractive and welcoming and
open again
so i guess you'll support uh this
government initiative of 56 million
to to welcome business uh we'll welcome
customers back and to help businesses
to do that um there's a lot of that work
is going on at the moment and of course
to be honest i don't imagine 56 million
when you give you that up across the
country
actually is going to mean an awful lot
more for us i don't know how much we're
going to get in newcastle i hope we'll
get some of it
but we will just get on with things
anyway um
and a lot and all of our businesses
really have have already got
very mature and practice plans to make
sure that we can get people back into
town
back into shops back into businesses
safely and we're really looking forward
to the opportunity to do that
do you think the 56 million isn't enough
from the sounds of it you're suggesting
that it
it might not be um i don't know how much
of that we're going to see in newcastle
i think
i think generally across the piece the
government's support has been
has been extremely good um there are
sectors of the economy
um who are really scraping um you take
nightclubs for example who have
been shot for a year um and they only
really started to get some meaningful
help
um in november um and a lot of that
for a lot of them you know that barely
barely touches the sides when you look
at their fixed property costs so it's
still extremely difficult for a lot of
businesses
yes you can see how that that is the the
case in terms of the high street though
how do you see it changing and well
changing in order to survive it in the
future we just
really going to keep on using online
businesses is that
is that the future i think um over the
last
year we've sort of seen probably seven
years worth of impact on the retail
sector
and really what towns and cities have
got to do quickly
is to evolve so that the quality of the
offer
how a city curates itself to provide
different things for different parts of
the community
um all of that's got to happen pretty
quickly um
certainly in newcastle um we have got
fantastic plans coming forward there's a
we've just launched up 50 million
pound vision for the city center that
will be rolled out over the next
10 years but actually we're going to see
you know 20 million pounds worth of that
investment coming forward over the next
sort of 18 months to 24 months so it's
actually it's really really exciting and
i'm looking very much looking forward to
it
you do sound very optimistic about the
future are you
yes i absolutely am i mean obviously i
would say that wouldn't i
um but there's huge pent-up demand i
think amongst
businesses to get going to do what they
do best you know they're vibrant
organizations and they want to get their
customers back and they want to do what
they do best and know how to do
so we're we're looking forward to april
and getting going again can't wait
brilliant uh great to end on a positive
note uh adrian modell thank you very
much for speaking to us
thank you
also making the news today a volcano has
erupted near iceland's capital reykjavik
following thousands of
small earthquakes in recent weeks
streams of lava have been seen at the
fagradaal mountain volcano which last
erupted
800 years ago the city is just 20 miles
away
and officials say they expect gas
pollution to spread
across the country's southern coast
beautiful but deadly australia's east
coast has been hit by severe flooding
after record-breaking rainfall
evacuation orders have been issued in
new south wales and authorities have
asked people in sydney
to stay at home
nas is here with the weather now i've
got two words for you
now was barrack oh thank you i thought
you were going to be real
no explain what they mean
it's happy new year in farsi that's the
iranian language
and that's because today at 9 37 a.m
it's the spring equinox which is
the start of the rainy new year so salon
or mobarak
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so today is the spring
equinox this morning
and we are going to see some good spells
of spring sunshine out there
as well but there will still be a fair
amount of cloud around with some drizzle
too so it's a real mixture of conditions
this morning it's sunny but it's chilly
with the local frost across central
southern and eastern parts of scotland
parts of northern england
down towards the southeast of england
there is a bit of brightness too fairly
cloudy elsewhere with some patches of
mist and fog out towards the west
now going into this afternoon there will
still be large amounts of cloud around
and where the cloud gets thick enough
there may be a bit of drizzle as well
but the cloud will tend to break at
times so i think there'll be a bit of
brightness
later especially across parts of wales
and midlands the southwest of england
central and southern parts of ireland
but the southeast i think will tend to
cloud over although kent
will probably still hold on to some
sunshine the best of the sunny spells
will be across the northeast of
england and for most of the day across
central southern eastern scotland but
across northern scotland there will be
a front approaching there with brisk
winds and that will sink some clouds
towards central parts of scotland later
where it will turn
a little bit hazy with that sunshine too
it's now been a year since pubs were
first forced to close their doors due to
the pandemic
in that time almost 10 000 licensed
premises including pubs clubs and
restaurants closed
permanently at the end of january more
than four million jobs were still
furloughed and 68 percent of employers
using the furlough scheme were from
accommodation and food services
the highest of any sector katharina
vertotsi reports on the industry's
struggle for
survival at the heart of this
rural derbyshire village is its pub
but a year ago today everything stopped
i mean we've been abreast of the news so
we knew that things were starting to get
bad
we didn't it still never felt like a
shutdown was coming
um and yeah the realization
kind of brutal we thought
weeks not months not a year
because of local tier restrictions this
pub was last open
in early november a punishing closure
that at times felt
unsurvivable it's been like 15 20 years
of building this business up to what it
is now and we have 68 staff i think on
furlough
currently um but the team is bigger than
that still if we take in the sort of
students that come back in the summer
and then yeah it's kind of been brutal
we've taken on
significant amount of debt to
have us come through this and but we're
confident we'll bring it back but it
doesn't make it any less painful
or difficult
thanks to furlough support takeaway
options and
share will this pub is getting ready to
reopen
but around 2000 venues won't without
more financial support
industry bodies say others will follow
the support that is required for pubs
and many industries not just pubs but
you know particularly pubs and
hospitality
he's going to be needed for i believe
years to come there are a lot of pubs
out there that are going to be opening
into a very uncertain environment our
custom base have got used to drinking at
home
and we don't know whether they're
necessarily all going to come back the
next few months
are critical see these tents they've
been put up to boost numbers for outdoor
drinking and dining come mid
april whatever the weather we don't know
what we're going to open to
how busy or whatever so we're just
making sure that we
start slowly and kind of
you know and then sort of build it back
up and that will be key
here and elsewhere in a year where so
many things have changed
will our drinking habits be yet another
caterina vatsi sky news in derbyshire
following the killing of george floyd in
the united states one response was a
series of global bakery sales to raise
money to support the black community
next week london bakers against racism
will be holding their biggest sale so
far
as they raise funds for a project to
address a lack of black history in
schools
maxine mummy with a den bake shop in
harlem in north west london joins me now
good morning to you
first of all tell me how london bakers
against racism came about
and what exactly it is that you're
trying to do
good morning thanks for having me um so
london bakers against racism came
about because two different sets of
people one in northeast london one in
north west london um saw what was
happening
um you know we all had a very visceral
response to the
murder of george floyd um bakers against
racism began in dc
in in the united states and we basically
picked up the mantle over here
so back in june we had two sails
um and as you said this is our biggest
sail ever
we came together for black history month
as well um
and now we have our four london hubs
northeast northwest
southeast and southwest and this is our
biggest ever
uh sale and on life now so exactly how
how does it work how do people get
involved so people visit our website
um bakers against racism ldn.co.uk
they select their collection hub which
are the lockdown bakehouse in wandsworth
um brown and green life in crystal park
crystal palace park uh the half in
northwest london queens park or estes
cafe and stone newington
and they buy um so bakers across london
pro bakers and very seasoned home bakers
have donated
their bakes and we're pre-selling
everything
and then customers can come and collect
it on sunday the 28th of march
from one of those hubs so so you have uh
amateurs
contributing as well not just uh
professional
we say amateurs but you know these are
people that have been
you know selling on the side they're
just not registered food businesses
um a lot of people have had to pivot
very hard during this lockdown so you
have
pro pastry chefs um who haven't been
able to
find another role who have now kind of
set up on their own and so on and so
forth so
yeah we've it's predominantly pro bakers
and pro
pastry chefs uh who are doing this on
the side and everybody is
donating fully um without sponsorship
and
everybody's just doing this because we
really feel like we need to do something
to
combat racism in this country so i won't
be sending you any of my uh
baking then you'll be you'll be you'll
be saved that
everything's thoroughly checked
what are you insinuating um what exactly
is that the money going to be used for
that you're hoping to raise
so this time we are raising funds for
the black curriculum
um and they are a group of
relatively young folks actually young
black women predominantly
who have been really pushing to get
black history taught
in the national curriculum making it
mandatory at the moment schools can
adopt parts and most schools will make a
big push during black history month but
obviously
there is a lot of history of black
people in the uk that
is just simply not in history books
doesn't appear in the curriculum
and doesn't help in terms of
understanding the contribution that
black people have made to this country
and therefore combating racism too
you said that london bakers against
racism followed on from the the american
project um what would you say to those
that say that uh
racism and the the issues surrounding it
really is
an american problem and doesn't exist in
the uk
there are a lot of those people that
still feel that way i'm hopeful
that events over the past year have
at least begun to open their eyes um
it's not the same
we didn't have the slave trade here but
you know
britain did a really good job
unfortunately of just exporting those
problems and kind of doing the dirty
work elsewhere
you know i am here because britain was
there i am here because
britain was in jamaica you know my
husband is here because britain was in
nigeria there's
any number of things you can point to
that wouldn't exist
but for empire um including the
industrial revolution we don't talk
about those things
in the context of the slave trade and we
also don't talk about black history
outside the context of the slave trade
so there's a lot of evidence
um i think there's a point at which
people choose not to recognize that
racism
is systemic and really needs
firm addressing here in the uk and in
essence it's not actually black history
it's
all of our history isn't it um i wonder
if you can just tell us what you'll be
baking today to make us all hungry
so for me i'm offering a box of macarons
so pistachio
mango chocolate and salted caramel
macarons
i'm doing original nutter cake and
carrot cake too but there's plenty on
sale
still we're still going and if you can't
get to the sale yourself
you can always make a donation through
our invisible cookies on our website
and what time did you say my parcel
would be arriving
unfortunately i didn't you'll have to
come see us and get it
i'd love to do that i'd love to order
some of that in i want to thank you so
much for speaking to us this morning
thank you very much
you are watching sky news breakfast
much more still to come do stay tuned
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
very good morning to you today is the
spring equinox
and there will be some spring sunshine
about particularly across northern and
eastern areas
but there is going to be a fair amount
of cloud around for today generally
in fact it's quite cloudy out there this
morning there's some drizzle where the
cloud is thick enough some patches of
mist and fog out towards the west but
there's
a bit of brightness down towards the
southeast where it's a chilly start with
the local frost
and over central southern eastern
scotland and northeast england there is
also some sunshine but it's chilly with
frosty conditions
now through today these spots will
continue to see the best of any sunshine
although it does start to cloud over
across parts of the southeast but i
think kent would just about hold on to
some brightness and a bit of brightness
will develop where the cloud breaks at
times over wales the midlands the south
west
and central and southern parts of
ireland but predominantly cloudy over
these areas central
southern and east and scotland will see
good sunny spells too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's at 7 43 you're watching sky news
breakfast coming up after the break
we'll take you through the stories
making this morning's
newspaper do stay with us
[Music]
when the industry shut down over a year
ago now
there was a situation quickly developed
where there's going to be a catastrophic
loss of skills knowledge and experience
in the live music industry
this is about audio lighting video pyro
stage building highly skilled
technicians who haven't worked in the
industry for
over a year and no live show is going to
happen
without these highly skilled technicians
and the support is about
putting the necessary structures in
place that they can come back to live
music from
maybe stacking shells or driving
delivery trucks whatever it may be
the the live music industry is so
important to this country it's a 1.3
billion uh contribution to the gdp of
the country the music industry itself is
5.2 billion in the uk
and as i say we're we're potentially
facing a
catastrophic loss of skills with these
highly skilled technicians
[Music]
the live industry isn't going to come
back immediately after june the 21st
at the earliest it's going to be a very
slow process and initially it's only
going to be domestic activity
and if you think that for a medium to
large size
gig to put five people on the stage is
approximately 200 crew members and those
200 crew members without which
the live music scene which we all love
so much which gives so much
value and meaning to our lives is not
going to exist and that
as i say the knowledge and experience of
these members of these
crew members is absolutely incredible
and the british music industry is going
to be at a
severe loss if they don't return to the
industry
and the support that we're raising funds
for so it's on the just giving page if
you just
look for uk metal merger the support is
to
provide all the necessary means for them
to return to live music and it's not
just financial support
there's mental health support stagehand
trained people in mental health
first aid and they also provide
addiction rehabilitation in in rare
cases
and it's a really really important
organization
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked roll
bikes and scoots to school
we would make a big difference to the
air pollution around our school
yeah like us
there will be largely cloudy skies today
with some drizzle in places too as well
as rain spreading southwards from
northern scotland
however there will be sunny spells at
times across central southern and
eastern scotland as well as northeast
england
and there will be a bit of brightness
for kent wales the midlands
and southern parts of ireland too so in
regards to the air pollution levels
today on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will remain at a low level
of one to three again
however there may be isolated pockets of
moderate air pollution around
urban areas and busy roadside locations
in the light winds the air quality
report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
welcome back with us this morning again
to take us through the newspapers the
editor of the young people's news site
challenges northern ireland that's
thomas copeland
and the broadcaster and journalist athia
on welcome back to you both
starting with you thomas first of all
and the telegraph and they're reporting
on
nicolas sturgeon's uh continued woes and
this is the the reporting to come of the
the second um report into whether
she misled parliament that's right this
the sturgeon salmon
crisis is just getting messier and
messier julian it's turning into a
political knife fight so this is a
report you'd be published on tuesday it
looks like it's going to say that
sturgeon did mislead parliament
but it'll stop short of whether of
saying whether she did so
knowingly and that's very critical in
terms of the ministerial code of conduct
smp committee members already accusing
their opposition
colleagues of forcing through
prejudicial assertions based on
political
uh connivance and prejudicial
opinions basically on nicola sturgeon
now it is obviously the case that you
know the tories for example
from the beginning have said that they
thought that sturgeon was in the wrong
that doesn't necessarily mean of course
that the conclusions of the committee
aren't valid
the problem with all of this for nicolas
sturgeon is it is twofold one
in in kind of deriding the conclusions
that are coming out of this committee
the smp leader has placed even more
emphasis
on the report that's due to be published
from james hamilton who is the former uh
chief of the head of prosecutions for
for ireland actually
as to whether she broke the ministerial
code of conduct
and by placing more emphasis there it
means that if that doesn't go her way
she doesn't really have anywhere to hide
and the other problem is that this
entire
sorry affair has created i think a kind
of aura
of scandal ever so it's like toxicity
around the snp
just before walking into an election
cycle has that tainted nicola sturgeon
i don't know but what i do know is that
the snp will do basically anything to
keep her in place she's a star player
she is a world-class politician i think
objectively a lot of people can say that
she's been hugely influential for the
independence movement
and they will do almost anything to keep
her in place including
delegitimizing the findings of a
parliamentary committee
and as you say she is she is the style
of snp there doesn't seem to be another
name
in the frame does there let's move to
the guardian affia this story about um
black history being made compulsory
on the curriculum in welsh schools
absolutely so like you said there
jillian all welsh pupils
are to be taught about racism and the
contributions
of black asian and minority ethnic
communities
um and that's according to the welsh
devolved government
so this is something that people have
been campaigning for
for a long time there was an upsurge in
petitions
last year with the resurgence of the
black lives matter movement
that black history which is all of our
history to be honest
should be taught in schools and i think
this is really important to do because
like i said this is british history
this is all of our history not just
black history
and it's also very important to
recognize the contributions
of black and asian community and other
people of colors
at communities contributions to the
united kingdom
over the years beyond slavery and beyond
colonialism
and a lot of the conversations that we
have around black history
tend to be only those things and i think
it's really important
that children in school learn about more
than these things
another part of what's being made
compulsory is that they're going to have
more training
for black and minority ethnic teachers
um to go into school so to encourage
more of them to be in schools and that's
really important
for black children for children of color
to see people
like them in education as well as more
support
for those teachers in schools as well so
i think this has been a long time coming
it's great that the uh the devolve
government in wales
have put this into practice that is
going to be compulsory and this is
something that i would like to see
rolled out across the united kingdom
because like i said black history asian
history and minority ethnic history
is just part of british history and
should be taught
beyond racism beyond colonialism in all
of our schools
and significant for all children thomas
to the times
and uh dominic cummings he's going to be
spilling
more beans it's the great return of
dominic cummings the times have a
a wonderful story of the pandemic they
call it a timeline
you can see a bit of it there i think on
your screen at the moment dominic
cummings has confirmed that he's going
to be
appearing in front of a joint committee
of mps to investigate lessons that
should be learned from covet 19
this is the first of what will
undoubtedly be a great many number of
inquiries into actions that were made by
the government over the course
of this pandemic it all comes down in
this case to decisions that were made in
early september around five days
as to whether the uk should enter a
short short sharp
lockdown at that stage rather than about
a month and a half later
as it eventually ended up happening
cummings we are told was at the
forefront of advocating for this short
sharp lockdown the change the charge
really is that boris johnson according
to him and his allies
dithered and delayed was concerned about
the economy was concerned about his
backbench mps wasn't convinced
that the lockdown was the most
successful way of
keeping hold of this virus i think you
know there are two things here
one how much of this is spin we don't
really know donna cummings was of course
fired in the end or let go from number
10 downing streets
after and particularly you know after
the barnard castle incident
uh some people accusing him of trying to
rewrite history
the other thing is will it make any real
difference my feeling is probably that
it won't boris johnson's in
a positive place when it comes to
political opinion at the moment the sun
shining on him a little bit that's those
the words that are used
in the article with the vaccine rule out
going quite well people are
looking upon him favorably a lot of that
is down to things like the vaccine
and there's objective analysis here as
well for example whales
entered into that short sharp lockdown
at the time that dominic cummings was
advocating for it in england
and they didn't really see a large
difference in terms of the number of
cases that came out
at the other end i think the reality is
you know the people who hated dominant
comings beforehand will hate him at the
end the people who love bars beforehand
will love him at the end
i wonder though as they finish how many
people who have described dominant
cummings in the past as being not
credible a liar perhaps somebody who was
just hungry for power
will be taking his word in the inquiry
as gospel
but we'll have to wait and see yes we
shall indeed uh just quickly time for
this last story
i definitely don't agree with this this
is a recommendation to get rid
of children's school uniforms by a cross
cross bench pier i say no what do you
say
i i say no as well this
actually started because the house of
lords yesterday were having a debate on
a proposed law to make
uniforms more affordable which i
actually think is really important
because
especially if you have to buy your
school uniform from
a specialist school shop it can be much
more expensive
than buying generic school uniform uh up
and down the high street and if you've
got more than one child that back to
school uniform shop can be
super expensive so the isle of plancarty
yesterday in the house of lords
proposed that actually we should get rid
of school uniforms
now we know that school uniforms are a
great leveler everybody goes to school
wearing the same thing and what we don't
want is for children to feel that they
don't have the latest gear
the latest trainers latest genes the
latest track dates
and that can lead to bullying now uh the
earl of pancarti said that his 16 year
old daughter
uh had said to him that she's glad that
she has a way to express herself
by not wearing school uniform and i do
think that's a point that needs to be
taken on board
definitely like i said uniforms are a
yes from me i think they should stay
thomas and mafia see you in an hour's
time